aïe aïe aïe avant la soirée mousse avant
de passer le coup de fil aussi pour la
regagner la table vous les contrats ce
tracé et gagner la table tout de suite
comme sa lésion et des branches
tranquille parce que y voilà autant
qu'on passe un bon moment on appelle
tout de suite pour faire gagner la table
ce soir à quelqu'un c'est parti sur
twitter hashtag table vous êtes très
très nombreux d'ailleurs a tweeté ce
soir ça va je vais m'en sortir ou pas
sûr au niveau de dca tient deux dé la
table ça va se passer je suis assez
sympa avec vous ouais ouais bah oui
après allo allo ma chérie alors oui
comment tu t'appelles mathieu oui c'est
ça va c'est qui c'est qui ce chan a
shoshana non fiona eve ou benayoun
tunisienne johann hay
le match aller tranquille elle s'appelle
fiona effet nantais chouchane a ajouté
harvey a été nommé sans rigoler c'est
quand même un boum ça oui je suis fiona
fiona vous habitez où j'habite à cholet
ma chérie tu vois fiona vous avez quel
âge
fiona je vous voulez gagner la table
vous avais prévenu vos parents sont
d'accord là sont d'accord vous avez vous
allez la mettre où parce qu'elle est
grande à fiona
je voulais vous faire un très gros
bisous fait quoi dans la vie elles
viennent facilement ben non c'est les
résultats ces noces est là bon alors on
est bien on les moyens à cake
ça devrait passer fiona je t'envoie la
table match 4
on a kiffé fiona qui fait maintenant cd4
tiers pour ceux qui nous rejoignent ce
qu'il ya plein de nouveaux
téléspectateurs qui nous rejoindre
surtout en prime jean luc lemoine vous
vous appelez à ce qui se passe pendant
les pubs dans l'émission exactement
donc voilà ce qui se passe que disent
les gens relation secrète exact ils ne
restent pas secrètes donc c'est des gens
qui posent des questions moi j'essaie de
répondre du mieux que je peux exactement
allez tout de suite une question bonjour
je m'appelle françoise il y a trois
semaines vous avez dit que vous alliez
tout déstocker pour cette dernière
donc est-ce que vous allez montrer qu'en
syrie l'afrique derrière le décor et
surtout quand jean michel a joué au
tennis avec sa batterie non
non françois je sais que je l'avais dit
mais ce soir j'ai envie de tout changer
jésus j'ai tout changé je vous aimez
marcher puis tout à l'heure cette
dernière j'ai plutôt envie de rendre
hommage à mes camarades et en premier
lieu mon meilleur d'entre nous cyril
parce qu'il faut dire que le petit fils
dans une émission en direct c'était bien
concentrés avant la prise d'antenne donc
dans ce home est le meilleur c'est lui
regardez cette maîtrise et sa mousse
annoncé comme une excuse les moustiques
de l'anus ou ici connaît tous les
insectes aura engagé dans le changement
de ton nous sommes de retour
ces trous david pujadas il fait pareil
merci est un homme remarquable et
courageux car même quand il est
souffrant et bailly laisse rien paraître
les restes souris durant l'antenne
booster encore très mal à tout le monde
je serai toulousain
voilà mes chéris ces trois séquences
préférées dans adaptant je vous donnerai
l'invité d'aujourd'hui
franchement vous avez du courage quand
même parce que vous étiez malade et les
autres rigolent derrière finalement je
vais un peu déstocker ce soir le comme
une ex c'est formidable parce que c'est
le confessionnal de cyril c'est
l'endroit où le demi-dieu redevient un
homme baba comme nous tous ce n'est pas
lui raconter quoi je me suis je les
reconnais que je me suis jeté dessus
c'est drôle avec les chefs on a compté
dans un instant
rancourt le fils tout de suite cette
date est un génie non non mais c'est
vrai mais le moment à la prise antenne
en animation c'est très important
c'est ce qu'il a mais on parlera des de
l'alcantara après non mais c'est ce qui
donne le là ce qui va suivre lyonnais
qui sont très didactique dans leur façon
animée qui explique tout ce qui va se
passer au public comme une aura au
passage
écoutez bien le public vous allez enfin
savoir ce qu'il aime dans nos
enregistrements alors vous expliquer ont
fait l'émission un peu dans le désordre
parce qu'il la mamie qui vient donc on
va pas la libérer non plus à 3 heures du
matin et une fois que mamie est parti il
y aura des buts et d'alcool
vraiment dégueulasse j'étais pas là bon
vu le cri de joie le public vient
surtout pour les [ __ ] et d'alcool
autres écoles julien courbet lui avant
l'antenne il fait pas de fausses
promesses c'est un mec droit c'est un
mec francs quand vous avez offert une
belle petite émission de merde oui un
peu dépressif quand même il faut dire
que c'est la fin de saison et tout le
monde est fatigué pour prénom jean
michel c'est l'image jean-michel calme
toi alors beaucoup beaucoup de gens me
demandent si jean michel est vraiment un
fêtard et surtout comment ils se
comportent en boîte et bien comme tous
les faits tels et les cliques et il
reste en bord de piste fait deux trois
mouvements des bras et dit n'importe
quoi pour faire jeune
c'est impossible raya jours le ca trù
jean michel est bien opérationnel c'est
sur les invités dès qu'une fille rentre
il est persuadé qu'elle a craqué sur lui
il ya peu nous recevions la très belle
christina cordula et le moins qu'on
puisse dire c'est que jean michel a été
très séduit par les pommettes saillantes
de la belle brésilienne
impossible aussi valoir que ça cesse
ce soir je montre tous ces bons souvent
si les invités nous disent des choses à
l'oreille quand ils rentrent pas ce que
vous ouvriez murmuré à trouver et bien
la réponse est oui
il ya même une belle complicité là
c'était sophie tapie
en effet juste après mais je n'ai pas
monté par david a en tout cas sophie et
nora sont très complices presque autant
kenora et isabelle regarder ce beau
moment de partage où isabelle avait
besoin de se confier
non non
m
oui c'est grâce à ces liens forts que
l'émission est ce qu'elle est on est
unis on se serre les coudes
l'autre jour thierry était triste car
s'ils avaient oublié de présenter très
blessé conférence
et surtout de suite tu te sens mieux
hein mais nadège aussi été assez embêter
on ne m'a parlé tout à l'heure dans la
quotidienne car ce qu'il s'était moqué
de son mec qui ressemblerait à régis
laspales et ses soeurs et les bourses
trop tard il est parti donc à la pause
suivante elle était vraiment pas bien
nadège heureusement dans les coups durs
on peut toujours compter sur les amis là
c'est valérie benaïm a alors écoutez
bien je pense que c'est le réconfort le
plus maladroit de la décennie elle sans
doute ma vidéo préférée de la semaine
éditorial victoria c'est bon de vous
enfoncer pas christophe carrière et
prison ce soir ce qui est assez rare un
sort de carrière donc pour lui faire
plaisir
j'ai fait un petit montage pour résumer
son année dans touche pas à mon poste
j'aime bien chez free c'est des malades
chef des fouilles et s'arrête donc à
travailler avec des gens comme ça avec
vous vous êtes autant plus fous non non
non franchement voit sa maman christophe
ça va ça c'est des comptes et à la fin
oui ça va tout va bien pas la mer silva
c b comprend bien mais pas son temps
festival de cannes
oui les chroniqueurs ont beaucoup évolué
cette année isabelle par exemple avant
on faisait une émission de télé bah
maintenant les dans son salon si je
pouvais la mènerait son plein et de
regarder
mais aussi un peu
c
sa priorité bien parce que je pense
qu'il eût monde
c'est un non sens
et dans l'oreille elle va chercher des
trucs c'est pas ça la rend d une jeep
non je peux rêver nature isabelle à part
ça je vous avais montré la dernière fois
la jouette d'enora quand elle est
appelée par ce terrible pour le coming
next rappelez vous le 14 et ben du coup
pour ne plus avoir ce genre de réflexion
on appelle l'autre côté de la table qui
lui est très content
n'oublierai pas pendant les vacances je
peux vous dire l'année prochaine
taiwo dans le temps merci jean luc sinon
il peut pas j'ai l'impression que stasi
c'est horrible je ne peut pas s'empêcher
jean-michel une nouvelle fois imité
n'aura qu'à regarder
oui
d'amour
tellement ça bravo boulodrome lors de la
venue d' arthur pour encadrer le circus
on avait tous étaient déguisés en
artiste de cirque
on savait que c'était des déguisements
le seul qui a vraiment cru qu'il avait
un don c'est jean-michel parce que ça
peut être dangereux ça prenne son treuil
plaisant français veulent faire aller
souper j'ai pas les boules de geisha
attention merci le cadre d'un gala à sa
magnifique voix là c'est quand même
assez bon c'est quand même le plus lourd
de france
le concert
payer des gens comme ça c'est le concept
rasions dont un amusant c'est long ça
nous avait déjà fait des valeurs
mieux les arguments bon titre n'est pas
le lourd
on regarde le circuit j'avais aussi
l'homme élastique qui peut étendre sa
peau ouais
c'est fort c'est ma vie
bon franchement vous faites honte je
vais prévenir ça pique un peu mais il
faut le reconnaître il a changé bertrand
cette année il a changé bertrand c'était
l'année de l'émancipation
avant quand ils pensaient poser des
questions indiscrètes vas-y botté en
touche juste par pudeur avec un cas non
jamais je suis une princesse
je vais vraiment je suis désolé désolé
pour votre sarkozy co désolé écouter
vraiment mais c'est plus le même jeu
vous dit bertrand vous l'avez trop gâté
vous avez eu la gentillesse de mettre en
un an sa rubrique à 19h05
puis à 19h 20h puis à 19h40 puis à 19h58
est maintenant à 20h05 tout ça pour
qu'il a rendez-vous réguliers et oui
hein quand même série bichonne bertrand
et bertrand est d'ailleurs très sensible
à toutes les attentions
non
en train d'élaborer sous le nom mais qui
me touche c'est rageant
au moins un texto la semaine dernière
j'ai pas eu de réponse dans les textos
je réponds pas je vous le dis faut pas
pêcher pas votre numéro où je te vois
qu'ils aient si vous les 60
c'est ça c'est 07 kidjo et 0 c'était
creuserait 07 60 quelque chose ouais je
sais mais faut arrêter de l'ex numéro je
n'aime pas c'est tout je n'aime pas me
rappeler qu'un autre n'y a eu
heureusement cyril il peut se consoler
face à sa gratitude
grâce au soutien d'un public fidèle et
et notamment trois femmes qui avaient
été menées dans le public et si il avait
l'air de très bien les connaître il ya
des sus depuis des années allez chirila
d'intérêt en chine ça va vraiment le
coup dit aujourd'hui
il ya eu des bacs cali cyril elle me
suivent non c'est pas ça c'est très
clair ça se joue entre elles me suicide
on depuis des années ce qui veut rien
dire ou en tout cas c'est bien d'être
proche de son public
si vous voulez écouter vous écoutez bien
s'ils y regardaient suisse depuis des
années entre passons cyril les agents de
sécurité il ya mokhtar mais il ya aussi
audel au delson à exactions d'hommes et
audel mais cyril l'adorent comme nous
tous
donc pour lui témoigner sa sympathie il
va commencer par lemaitre un gros vent
et après improviser une chanson à sa
gloire
sama audel qu'un enfant audel audel
audel audel on veut voir ta rondelle
audel audel on veut voir la rondelle
audel
j'aime bien va-t-il chercher tout ça
j'aime le directeur des programmes
francs capitaux qui se cache derrière
qui se dandine un peu j'aime bien quand
même
voilà je pouvais tout vous montrer ce
soir qu'il y avait encore beaucoup à
déstocker des trucs à montrable comme je
passe du bon temps tout comme le nous et
nos rares regardez un extrait des
grosses têtes
le jour où ils avaient là complètement
craqué
seck
c'est incroyable le jour où on aura eu
un petit coup de mou repense à sa
passion pour la danse à
ça demain
mais bon pour finir et pour donner une
image assez juste de saison je m'étais
dit que le mieux était de faire un mini
zapping en mode bourré
merde
notre prochaine pardon pour tenir
quarante huit heures son tapis
c'est vrai d'accord évasion oui c'est
normal que c'est long mais je ne sens
pas une c'est la conscience morale
publique et école vous ai fait les
courses longues années un césar
n'importe quoi là qu'est ce que fait
lille importe ban a fait c'est fait
après la partie du coureur de flore au
plus haut mais c'est pas ce que vous
aimez bien symbole d'un bon oeil un
monde d'abondance c'est pas mal
un phoque c'est en fait très bien qu qui
paraît oui on va d'église et tout ça ça
va pas thébaux debeuret mamère debeuret
le
bien que mal
à quoi